I can't let's move on to the next
Conspiracy Theory what do you believe
well you think the moon landing is a
bang of conspiracy theory let me let me
tell you about the Avengers endgame of
conspiracy theories okay okay okay
because I'm going to tell you about
flatter oh [__] because despite all of
the scientific progress we have made in
the past few centuries they are all
wrong because did you know that the
Earth is actually flat it is flat all
right so well tell us how you came to
this conclusion Don how did she how did
you come to this conclusion well well
guys guys just just for for a second
just just open your
mind your mind mind okay the Sheep the
Sheep will believe that I am sheep stop
as a Welsh post I take offense to that
all right the Sheep will believe that
the Earth is actually round but if that
were true yeah the curvature would be
more visible to the naked
eye so when you when you observe the
Horizon yeah what do you see do you see
a curve uh what what shape is the
Horizon I guess it I guess it from my
eye it would appear it looks pretty The
Horizon where's the curve where is the
curve I'm sorry I'm sorry okay okay very
compelling so far my eyes do deceive me
all right not forgetting uh gravity as
well how how the hell does that make
sense gravity this invisible force okay
okay okay so so so you're telling me
that I could be upside down but still be
right side up
yes okay okay to Counterpoint the first
one uh I I to Counterpoint the first one
I think how they did it was uh they did
an experiment where they were like they
went out into like an open field where
like the Horizon was clearly visible
and they were all right I'm
just Horizon Bally if the is flat as you
say it is then you'll keep continuing to
see me for for as long as you know I am
there but no what actually happens is
that you start walking towards that
Horizon and then you start to dip due to
the curvature of the earth until you
disappear under the Horizon so that was
the theory that
they so that that shows that yes the
Earth is C it's just that we are so
insignificantly small compared to the
rest of the curve is not as apparent
there's way more scientific ways to
prove it pretty easily I think isn't it
uh no there of course there are
scientific ways that's just a very
simple like nonscientific look you see
it that it's curve I'm pretty sure one
of the ways that you disprove this
Theory uh at least the The Horizon
theory is that you can just uh I think
you just beam a light like a laser MH
from over a large distance and if the
Earth is flat right you have two points
pretty far away yeah uh if you just beam
a beam of light it should stay perfectly
flat so if you have two points far away
from each other then if you're right
then the the beam should uh stay perfect
but what happens is that the it dips
slightly so when you measure it from two
points it ends up being slightly lower
further away because the her's curvature
is causing it to dip how do you feel
about that how's that how do you how's
that do you reject that outright I I'll
reject that could be with even more
succinct points because Joey yeah as an
Australian if that really does exist if
that really does exist sh I came here
with you know you know as an Australian
all right in your round earth model you
know should Australians not just fall
off oh [__]
[__] I mean you know we we our toes grip
like [__] monkeys onto the ground
we're just like we're holding on to dear
life you know that's why that's why uh
drop bears are real like problem cuz
they're just consistently dropping off
the okay all right okay we're adding on
it yeah so cuz cuz like you know you can
get a flight to pretty much everywhere
pretty easily sure yeah but not the
Antarctica okay like why why is that why
do the establishments do not want you to
fly to Antarctica cuz there's [__]
don't tell me there's nothing there no
it's not nothing there it's cuz it's too
unhospitable we can't it's too cold I
mean if you'd like to go you know place
where it's- 50° C on average all year
then sure they're not afraid that we're
not going to just fall off the Earth if
we find the massive ice wall that is
surrounding the entire the entire I
don't know what they don't call it a
globe do they they call it they must
call it something she a
sheet um I mean you know to people like
that I say hey man there are ways that
you can go to Antarctica it's maybe a
little unconventional but it's not like
an imp say you're saying the lack of uh
flights to Antarctica proves that the
Earth is flat I'm saying that's because
airlines are stopping
Customs just part of that yes you're on
the plane right if we do all the time
you travel a lot you look at the little
fun little map why is it not a straight
line G to from you know America to Japan
it's a curve following the curve that
how you know that it's how do you know
that the map that you're getting
presented that's part that's that's
sheeple thought you're getting presented
a map that they presented you with and
you're believing it without any question
it's a pre-programmed map flight of
course they're going to model it after
the model they're trying to sell to you
Conor okay when you watch your boat sail
away right the boat just goes away it
goes oh like it disappears right if it
was flat you just keep seeing it no it's
so far away that you lose sight of it
exactly thank you Joey thank you thank
you Jo I'm waking
up if it was a clear day you could
theoretically see any kind of large
object in the distance if yeah you can
if your eyesight's good if it was flat
but the you on his side now whatever the
[__] happening hey I'm convinced I'm
starting to be convinced a little bit
yeah watch uh without being in the sky
it's impossible to see the curvature of
the earth however you can always see a
demonstration of this if you visit any
Harbor or place with a wide open view of
water uh if you're able to watch a ship
sail off to Sea this is what I was
saying earlier with someone walking off
into with Hill with with like walking
it's a little different
obviously the ground is not always oh
yeah but if hypothetically if you got a
fully fly ground same thing would happen
there's a lot of reasons why Okay g what
other reasons you have and you know
we're going to come back oh yeah here we
go yeah Pro I just just proved that yeah
we're we're going to come back to the
big establishments they you know they
they had their greatest hits with the
moon landing but NASA's back at it again
oh my God those feeding us the feeding
us their false photos their false
theories have you ever have you actually
seen seen a picture of the Earth that
has not been coming from a big like EST
I don't have a [__] satellite in
space g if I had one maybe I'd be taking
pictures sounds like your problem sounds
I don't know why would why would Nessa
lie to us why would they have what
interest is there in lying to us about
why wouldn't they lie to exactly exactly
because they're working with the
government and the government always
lies they're not just lying about
everything why would they lie about
everything what's the point in that so
they can control you it's like it's like
saying that you've been brainwashed it's
like saying that when they're like man
you got to lie you shouldn't drink this
much coffee in a day that's what they
tell me and I tell
them why would you lie why would they
lie about that why would they lie about
that look just think about it this way
okay sure
okay you you're asking why why would
they lie about it I can tell you plenty
of reasons all right okay you've seen
Attack One Titan yes you you you've seen
attack tit yeah why sometimes being you
know sometimes knowledge is blessing or
our lack of knowledge is a blessing we
do not know what's beyond what is beyond
that ice wall it could be like it could
be Game of Thrones we don't live on the
[__] wall we could be in the
continent from Hunter Hunter and we
don't know what the Dark Continent oh
[__] they might be protecting our safety
we do not know what is beyond the wall
beyond the war we are par we are the
island in Attack on Titan right now
we've been in chimra ant this whole time
look the Titans the Titans might be
there for our protection we just don't
know it who are we hiding from G what
what kind of Flat Earth we don't know
what what happens if I go to the edge we
don't know may maybe we don't know what
you get abducted actually you get
abducted how come that when I fly you
know when I fly the other way uh cuz you
know I've flown to the UK and I've gone
both ways how can I go both ways if it's
flat I surely I should only got to go
one way again that's the map falling you
yeah that's that's just the map do I
just clip to the other side when I get
to the edge a scen it work if I fly if I
fly West or I Fly East why do I always
end up in the same spot well you don't
you have you've never done it what do
you what do you mean what do you mean
I've never done it have you ever flown
in One Direction and have you piloted
the plane yourself oh I look out the
window as a simulation on the window how
do you not know you're not flying in a
massive Circle yeah while you're
sleeping the pilot is slowly
appearing slowly turn it's slowly
turning long oh I'm sorry there's a
little bit of turbulence oh and again
that explains the curved flight part
yeah exactly exactly he's just very
slowly veering to the right or left no
no no no he's not they're not flying in
a curve they're flying straight because
the Earth is a curve straight is a curve
no no they're flying in a curve you just
don't feel it oh my God you're asleep
you're not awake for the entire 9h hour
flight to the US how would you know what
the [__] I am I have been I'm a Believer
now that's that's there's there's other
things but that's that's pretty much the
main kind of like
argument um well you you've uh you
convince me yeah to to break character
for a second um yeah please I was like
damn being a flat earther is fun holy
[__] like in terms of like just okay so
conspiracy theories right obviously a
lot of them are like [__] [__]
yeah but the thought itself is fun right
right the thoughts of just being in this
like playing devil certificate is always
you're you're basically making up your
own little Game of Thrones world now the
only difference is that it's dangerous
because you're applying it to real life
situations you're like no no no the
Wizarding World Is Real I'm pretty sure
this is how Georg R started off yeah I I
can see now why flat earther um world
building is just another level is World
build this here is the world that we are
building that's that's the whole point
that's the whole point some some like
the maps of like fat Flat Earth of like
what is beyond the ice wall is [__]
middle interesting you know um what's
this one the square and station area
what the [__] is this [__] this is like
some Final Fantasy Maps bro like yeah
it's great I love it yeah um I I think I
think a lot of this comes down to
obviously like I said a lack of trust in
establishments um I think Flat Earth but
what did you have to be fed in order to
have that kind of just all round
anti-establishment mental
that's what that's what I've always been
curious about well I mean unfortunately
there is a history of governments not
having the best interest and also
government speak some pretty [__] up
stuff that we do know they've done uh
stuff that would be conspiracy theory
worthy if we didn't know it was already
true right um so I think it kind of
stems from that kind of that kind of
line of thinking of like hey they've
already you know governments have
already done things like they've
sterilized populations or they've done
horrific experiments on populations we
know know this is true and this has
happened so it's unfortunate because
then it enables people to think well
well they well governments have done
this so why wouldn't they be willing to
do and hide even worse things yeah um
you know it's it's a it's an unfortunate
situation where yeah governments have
done really horrific stuff in the past
and it's kind of building upon that
distrust yeah yeah for sure espec
especially if you've know someone or
you've been affected uh by that you know
like obviously if you look at like
America uh certain groups have you know
obviously like Native Native people have
uh been very unjustly treated by the
government and so there's just a
distrust naturally that builds towards
the government and then as you would
have because you're like the government
has tried to [__] over me and my
relatives for the past hundreds of years
why the [__] would I trust anything they
say and
sometimes the the line between when that
is reasonable to have and believing
stuff that is a bit dumb online you know
but it's also hard cuz people it's very
easy to be pushed down these rabbit
holes online where you can be subjected
to this kind of stuff and think hold on
now these guys are starting to make
sense yeah everything you've read online
or in meteors your entire life growing
up has has been factual yeah because
let's let's think about this on like a
kind of like a barebones conceptual
level about what you can perceive with
your eyes um we we did think the Earth
was flat for a period in time for a good
reason because we look at the Earth
seeing is believing and uh we can
perceive the world as this way and then
you get into like modern science about
Concepts that not it's way harder to
wrap your head around you know the
concept of something like gravity than
it is the concept of just hey what if
you just fall off an edge you know yeah
I go down I think it also you know is
aided by the fact that over the course
of humanity and over the course of
scientific progression there have been
so many theories that at the time we're
like oh yeah this is absolutely correct
which just turned out to be absolutely
Incorrect and then we've had to make
small little adjustments so then I'm
sure a lot of these conspiracy theorist
will be like aha see not even scientists
can get a right 100% of the time so
what's to say that we're not right you
know and also I think just the kind of
like the idea of there being something
unknown or or like some some kind of
mystery out there it's just way more
enticing you know than just the boring
answer so like the idea of like what is
beyond this [__] ice wall that's
that's just like that's just like a cool
concept kind of I mean it it it goes
hard it I kind of you say I'm a red FL
the the world would be kind of cool if
there was just this looming ice wall
that would be sick but it unfortunately
it's kind of boring anarctica which we
also thought there was cool [__] there
at one point and we're like nope just
ice well we're still we're still finding
[__] you know we're still finding [__]
in Antarctica it could be some cool [__]
there we just haven't found it yet yeah
well I will say out of everything uh
flat earthers of course is one of the
Lesser believable ones of the ones we're
probably going to go for today but you
know what on a conceptual level I'm like
if this was actually real if if Flat
Earth was actually a thing I'd be
excited I'd be like why would you be
excited by that what cuz I want to be
the first one to break through the ice
yeah yeah yeah yeah want to be that guy
conceptually it's pretty exciting it's
just like Dam that's pretty cool
actually you know
I I I don't understand why people
actually believe that but I can
understand why this idea is like
appealing it's not it's not believable
but this collaborative fanfic people
have made about the FL Earth basically a
fanfic of yeah it's a collaborative
fanfic is uh is exciting let's just say
that it's it's interesting but uh not
believable at all it's an interesting
idea I'd rather I'll give I'll give it a
three I'll I'll I'll take you know I'll
go to Flat Earth if uh tagashi just
never finishes Hunter
Hunter maybe in another 10 years I'm
going to be like I need my Dark
Continent fixed somehow man I I need my
Dark Continent fixed what a flat Earth
Society just seemes like a spike after
that like well dark conent AR never
ended this is the closest he's going to
get God damn [__] ice world
yeah oh they have actual like other
continents that they've like figured out
as well this is just Hunter Hunter yeah
this this is literally Dark Continent
the ice wall is just Hunter Hunter I
love it all right so I I you know your
theory I'll unfortunately God I'm not
buying it it's cool but I give it a one
out of 10 for believability okay uh I'm
giving a extra points cuz it's fun fair
enough Fair what are you giving out of
10 three three we did a great job
arguing for it I think all right